I haven't read these books I mean Julie
have you read the books I had or have
you but by mistake I didn't know what I
was getting grades of hey on the outer
reaches of my awareness if you like not
just the people were talking about so I
just had a new Kindle so I ordered that
was people were talking about it bit of
a shock yes but I know the film is going
to be better because Jamie's much better
than my imagination I'm Kelly Johnson
now Oh Peggy of yours yeah yeah oh yes
now Susan I'm gonna have you read these
books no but it's nice to see a film
that's depicts people having sex in a
way that the vast majority the
population does I can't believe there's
anyone here who doesn't have a sex
torture chamber in their house yeah no I
haven't read the books I think okay so
here's it so just this is just this
isn't scientific so how many women here
so shout out how many women here I've
read the books okay and how many men
have read the books did you enjoy them
what I think about that is he said
they're shy yeah
just to be sure
1200 afternoon grab the knife is very
saw all the guests so thank you very
much now have you discover that you get
turned on by Hoover ducks if you need a
cleaner just ring me up and I said why
well because